- [Joe Hampton:] You know, there's a difference
between a kid who can play
basketball and a hooper.
You know, a hooper is someone
who can go get a bucket
at any given time for his team.
Someone just playing basketball
just knows the fundamentals
and just plays basketball the right way.
I guess there's nothing wrong with that,
but I'm a hooper for sure, for sure.
- [Eric Yeboah:] I wonder how it is that,
cuz you've had one of the more unique stories
out of everybody on the team with just, like, this
kinda like reintroduction to the world, right?
Everybody saw you on the
national stage in high school,
Oak Hill, what you did, and
now it's not, you know,
now you're reintroducing
yourself to a new world.
What was that like
getting comfortable also
with just, like, telling
your story about what
you've been through over
the last couple of years?
- [Hampton:] I mean, even though I
was, I've been through a lot,
a lot of ups and downs, like you said,
a lot of people knew who I was before,
and that's why I'm reintroducing myself.
But it was really easy
for me to open up to the camera crew
and tell my story because
they made it easy for us.
They were good people.
They were cool. They were open.
They told some of their stories.
And ultimately, I got comfortable
with telling my story because
they were real, and they were
good people. And it
just made it that much easier.
- The other things that you took
from that experience that you were, like,
hey, at the end of
the day, I needed that.
And like, what are others,
some of those other things
where you're like, yeah,
I definitely needed that experience
because it taught me this, this and this?
- Of course, [John] Mosley, in general, I mean,
I needed him too. He was a lifesaver.
God put him in my life for a reason
- [Yeboah:] Mmhmm.
- [Hampton:] at the perfect time.
And just everything that he
taught me with, like I said,
responding in the right way,
with not lashing out,
with just praying and just
seein' that, like, I'm OK.
And that if I do things the
right way that I'll be fine.
So Mosley, like, I needed him.
- [Yeboah:] Yeah.
- [Hampton:] For real. He saved my life.
- [John Mosley:] Don't put on a show.
You win the game.
Don't put on a show. You
freakin' win the game.
You don't put on the show.
You win! You get in the paint,
and you finish, and you win,
and you defend, you rebound,
and you play together. Come on!
- Let's go, let's get it.
- Let's go, let's go.
- [Mosley:] Hey, on three. 1, 2, 3, win!
- [Yeboah:] With the JUCO
experience in general,
I think a lot of people don't even know
that with a lot of the players
that there are so many sacrifices
that people end up there.
Everybody's not just
there because of grades.
Sometimes it's just sacrifice.
And I think even for you, like,
is that something you also
realized when you were there,
like, just hearing other stories
of other players and how they got there?
It's like, "Oh, they all have
similar stories or at least have
all been through something
while we're here," you know what I mean?
- Yeah, nah, really,
I mean, in that moment,
cuz Mosley, he was
gettin' on us about how we
weren't givin' it our all
and complaining
- Mmm.
- about not doing the extra.
And for him, it was like,
you're gonna come every day,
you're gonna give it your all
cuz ultimately you don't want to be here.
You don't wanna be in this place.
I don't want you here cuz you
need to be at the next level.
We wanna get you to the next level.
So you're going to do
everything
- Yeah.
- you're supposed to
to get to that level.
And at that point, he had enough
of us complaining, and he felt as if
we weren't giving it
our all and all of that.
So he was saying that
- Yeah.
- "I'm the one who's sacrificing to be in here.
I'm missing my daughter's softball game
and my son's practices, all of that stuff,
and you're complaining to me."
And, like, I felt, I mean, we understood.
We felt what he was talking about.
And in that moment we decided to
to reconvene and come as
a group, as the guys,
and get it together and do
the lift and get outta there.
But he was just trying
to make a point that,
I mean, you don't want
to be in this place.
The JUCO grind is real.
So you have to work just
that much harder just to get out,
you know what I'm saying?
- [Yeboah:] Yeah.
- [Hampton:] And that's tough.
- [Mosley:] Kid like Joe,
he knows how to play.
So I have to give him a chance
until he is a detriment to
everybody else in the program.
- [Yeboah:] It was also like,
I'm not gonna give up on you either.
So whatever it takes
for me to get you back,
I'm gonna go do it, which
is a shoutout to him for that.
- Right.
- That's nice stuff.
Do you have another one?
I know you said there was another one too.
- Yeah, yeah.
There's, I mean, there's
another good story,
like an inspirational story,
like as far as coaching. When I first came
to ELAC, I transferred
from Pasadena City College,
and my grades weren't good. I
was originally supposed to go
to Long Beach State from
Pasadena City College in 2017.
My grades weren't good enough.
I was slacking.
This was one of the times
I was a knucklehead,
open cases and stuff,
on the run, all of that.
And when I got the call
and someone told me like,
"Yo, go to Coach Mosley,
he'll help you out.
You go up there and just
do what you gotta do."
- Mmm.
- The meeting went great.
I got enrolled to school
and got into classes.
He told me about the guys. I met the guys.
Then I started to work out and practice.
I'm expecting to play.
Right?
- [Yeboah laughing]
- I'm expecting to...I'm practicing.
Practice uniform, going
to school, going to class.
Now I was, to be honest,
I'm slacking here and there.
Not showing up, doing my
usual slacking here and there,
but I'm in school and
going to class or whatever.
And he hits me with the, "You're
not playing this season.
You're here to get your
grades up and do what
you're supposed to off the court
- [Yeboah:] Mmm.
- [Hampton:] And
we'll worry about the court next year."
So my first time touching the
court was this past season,
"Last Chance U," what you seen.
- Oh, I got you. OK. OK. That wasn't
initially what you thought
it was going to be like.
You thought I was going to play, like, got you.
- I'm thinking I was going
to play at least two years
to get, you know what I'm saying?
- And bounce. Yeah, yeah.
- I wanted to get playin'.
You know, but he did the extra
- Yeah.
- to make sure that
I will be good now, you feel me?
- Yeah.
- It's not even me, Coach.
- Listen.
- I'm working hard.
- Listen. I know.
- I'm working hard for the team out there!
- Hey, listen, listen. And you are.
- [Yeboah:] What steps did you have to take?
I think a lot of people don't understand
that in between part, where it's like,
I have to now adjust, you know,
I did Penn State.
Then I did another
college, and now I'm here.
What is it like trying to
gather yourself and be like,
this is now the route that I have to go,
and I have to accept what it is
and what it's going to be like
so I can get to where I'm trying to go?
- It's a lot. It's a lot.
It's a toll mentally, really.
Because you really, you
have times where you
feel like, is this
really what I want to do?
Cuz I mean, like you said
- Mmhmm.
- I was at university, at Oak Hill
and I was playing this high-quality
D-I basketball
with all these good players.
And then I'll take a step back, and
I'm playing JUCO basketball.
Not necessarily bad
players. Still good players,
but it's not the same level of basketball.
- [Yeboah:] Yeah.
- [Hampton:] It's not the same clique that
I'm used to playing with.
And it was days where, like, I felt like
I wasn't getting any better
or going anywhere with it.
And it was taking a toll on me mentally.
And I had to really sit
down and think if like
this is really what
I want to do.
- Yeah.
- If this
is what I love, then I'm going
to fight adversity head-on,
and I'mma push through
it because it's light at
the end of that tunnel.
- Y'all was going to win it too.
But you know what I'm
sayin'? That's how it goes.
Best team. Appreciate each
and every one of y'all.
- [Yeboah:] You know, how we
saw how once COVID
canceled the tournament
for you guys, state,
I think everybody can agree
that that was one of the toughest finales
of any show that we've watched
from a viewer standpoint.
But being in it, like, what was
that like, just knowing
that you guys have put in so
much work, and then, you know,
it was done just like that?
What do you remember
from that moment the most?
- I just remember how
bad we wanted to win.
We worked for playing in
the state championship game.
- Mmhmm.
- That's what our goal was.
And everything that we
did leading up to it
was for that purpose, and
to get all the way up
to that point. And
no one did anything to affect it.
It's just, like, a natural thing.
Like, just something
that we can't control.
It was hard.
And to take that, it was tough.
- Yeah.
- You had emotions flowin' crazy.
Coach cried.
We, some of the players cried.
I cried.
What we wanted... state championship.
- Yeah.
- It was a waste.
- Nah, nah, and it shows, like right after that,
like you have an abrupt ending.
And then, I forgot who
mentioned it, but it's also, like,
that affects a lot of
everybody's, like, recruiting
or, you know, maybe college looks
that maybe woulda helped other people.
So it's done like that,
and then now we're just
sitting around chillin' for
the next whatever amount of months,
not knowing where you gotta head to next.
Do you remember those
in between months
between, you know, after it ended and before?
What was it like just chilling, waiting?
- Do I? I wasn't chillin',
I was panicking, bro.
I was panicking. Like I, because
for me, I wanted to be
a Division I basketball
player. I wanted to
get back to that stage,
to where I belong.
And I didn't wanna sell myself short.
I wasn't going Division II.
I wasn't going D-III. And no
disrespect to those programs
and those leagues or whatever,
I just couldn't do it there.
Like, that's just not
where I wanted to be.
That's not where I saw myself
excelling, and it was tough.
Like, I mean, I was panicking.
Like, if I was sitting around,
workin' out, staying ready,
just waiting on a call, stayin'
in touch with Coach Mosley.
Mosley would call me like,
"Yo, I talked to Long Beach.
They just said this and this and this."
And I'm getting hype and
waiting, waiting, waiting,
just sittin'. And then
randomly, out of nowhere
Long Beach called and told me like,
"Yo, like, come on. We want you," like.
- [Yeboah:] Wow.
- [Hampton:] Yes. We moved
there. And like, let's go.
And I'm like, ooh, we
goin' to Long Beach!
- I need to know, what
was in those churros, man?
What was in those churros, bro?
I need to know what was in the churros.
Do you understand how much I love churros?
- Excuse my language, man, but I
have to say it was crack in 'em churros, man.
[Both laughing]
- I'm sayin'.
- Those things were so good.
I don't know what he did,
like the guy who made 'em,
like he owned this little
churro business or whatever,
and it was bomb. Like, he had this like...
caramel, strawberry drizzle.
- It looked good.
- It was filled, it was crazy. It's a lot.
And if, like, if you got a sweet tooth,
it was perfect for you.
It was really good.
- That's what I'm sayin'! Yeah, I saw it,
I was like, yo, these dudes...
And the fact that you were like, yo,
I think you were like, yo, I could
definitely do some more of these.
Like, this ain't just the
first... I know what it is.
- I went there like three times in a
row, three days back to back to back.
- [Laughing] I respect it. I respect it.